circling the jade sea
is the dream of every merchant and the
other side is the golden empire of yeti
even its ruins dwarf every city in
westeros
and its princes are said to live in
houses of solid gold
and feast on meat powdered with pearls
and jade
foolish talk if it were true
i would have missed them long ago but a
bold merchant will risk two years for
one warrings
to fatten his holes with spices gems and
silks
so that he never wants for anything
again
to be fair many never do
because my ship silence finds them on
their return
their merchant dreams look so pitiful
poured out on my
decks not enough for any lifetime but
their own
a young man walks beside a girl across a
flowered field
spring has come and this girl is his
life
he prays a child climbs a tree to watch
the sunset over the fields
summer is ending and the harvest is life
for his village
he prays a hunter tracks a ball through
the woods
winter is coming and this boar is life
for his family
he prays but to whom do they pray
the world has as many answers as there
are men to answer
but walk far enough climb high enough
hunt long enough
and a man shall find only one one god
with many faces in the far east he is
the lion of night
who fathered the world's first emperor
on the maiden maid of light
and whose wrath nearly ended the world
in the house of black and white however
he is all of them and none of them
he is the many-faced god and wherever a
man turns
there he is men come from every corner
of the world to know him
to beg his favor and seek his gift for
themselves
if their life has grown too hard or for
others
who are making it so it is all the same
to the many-faced god
while adojus all men must serve him
beggars and kings while amor ghoulis
all men must die good and evil
men worship as they will but at the end
of every road
stands the many-faced god waiting
our city however would be quite a prize
for any empire
karth straddles two worlds a greedy and
curious west
and a rich and mysterious east the
marvels of yeti and asshai
pass through our markets and share
births with the riches of the free
cities
and westeros our ports have fulfilled
many a traders dreams
almost as many as they have broken
the maesters don't believe in prophecy
with good reason
the children of the forest supposedly
could see into the future
yet was surprised by the first men who
nearly ended their race
and the long night which nearly ended us
all even the wisest maesters however
have no answer for the red priests who
prophesy about the return of the long
night
for thousands of years they've kept
watch for the return of the prince who
was promised who will be born amid salt
and smoke to drive off the darkness once
again
prince of what realm promised by whom
and to whom
the prophecy doesn't say but at the very
least it confirmed that not even
essos escape a long night i imagine the
cataclysm must have confused the east
unlike westeros they wouldn't have known
of the night king or the white walkers
or the war wage by the first men and the
children of the forest
they would have just seen a terrible
winter descend and linga far too long
until spring magically returned to the
world
yet somehow maybe from passing merchants
maybe in their fires the red priest saw
the truth
you